[Music]
is there any good news in the polls for
Donald Trump at the six-month mark of
his presidency the simple answer is not
much he is less popular than any other
president of this plane is tenure in
terms of his overall approval rating
President Obama's approval rating the
summer of his first year in office was
around 60% Trump's approval rating
hovers around 40% president Trump gets
negative marks are handling foreign
policy and health care people are split
about his handling of the economy the
president still has the support of most
Republicans slightly more than 80% of
them have proven the job that he's doing
but large majorities of independents and
Democrats disappeared Democrats
especially disapprove intensely there is
one bright spot in an otherwise give
nerd coal lands good for the president
although Americans give Barack Obama
more credit than Trump for the economy's
resilient President Trump gets generally
positive marks on job creation and
keeping jobs at home both of which are
high priorities for most Americans how
do you think President Trump is doing
let us know in your comments also let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI